hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel and today
i am going to be reacting to t grizzy
robbery before i start this reaction do
not forget
to subscribe to my channel as you guys
know i'm trying every day to move out
kind of i kind of like it at home i'm
not gonna lie to you i kind of like a
little bit so
i'm trying but not that hard but still
subscribe
comment and like on the video on top of
that don't forget to follow my instagram
because on my instagram i do polls for
what songs i should do every week so
most of the time
when i pick a song it came from the poll
on my instagram
so make sure you follow my instagram the
link is in the bio
cause i threw too much money but i ain't
tripping i know that [ __ ] ain't no
dummy this mac got a 50 i leave his face
ugly get that [ __ ] at the crib
low okay so he says i'm walking out of
the club
and he's tripping because he threw too
much money so i'm guessing he's just
coming out of the strip club
low key i'm slipping before i knew it
this [ __ ] ran up on me
[Music]
okay so he just got robbed
not good not a good day for this guy
and he's saying he's not even tripping
he's giving the guy everything
he's probably thinking that
like it's a good thing you know money
and stuff
that can always be like replaced by your
life that can't so that's probably why
he just gave him everything
it's time to do some homework i gotta
put that boy to rest he look like a
killer i'm about to put him to the test
wanna kill me a [ __ ] all you see in my
face is death [ __ ]
on the ground scrolling through my
timeline chilling on some host page look
what i find
okay so he decided okay so
not what i thought before instead of
getting back at this guy
he is going to get eben so he's trying
to
kill the guy it looks like a stripper
[ __ ] post them as our mcm
[ __ ] same little [ __ ] was just in my
dm
you know what's up i'm splitting him i
see his whip i'm flipping that the
dealership won't want it back let me
write her back and get her contact
and call them killers okay so he's
saying
that there is a stripper girl that
he saw in his timeline that has been
dming him so she's been trying to like
get with him
she know he noticed that the guy that
robbed him
was her man crush monday so her
boyfriend i don't know why
if that's your man crush monday you
have you're like in other guys dms she's
probably not a very good girlfriend time
to do some contracts
matter of fact imma get them set up by
the stripper tell her i got 50. i know
that her gonna be with me
she [ __ ] so many [ __ ] i know she ain't
got no feelings and i'm sticking to the
cold when he drops she going with her
ain't talking to
oh wow so he's saying that the stripper
has hooked up with so many guys that
she won't even have feelings for the guy
that she's
hooking up with now um
okay [ __ ] turn witness going through
my ground she just hit me with them
ditches she said
call later cause she landed with her
[ __ ] oh yeah this might be my only
chance to do it
gotta shut his mouth before you talk so
she's
she's just waiting for this guy to leave
for the other guy to come over that's
what they say
to the streets right streets behavior
keep talking
[Music]
oh so he's trying to kill the guy
before he can tell the police
oh no no sorry he's trying to kill the
guy that robbed him
before the guy that robbed him can tell
anybody because if this guy dies
right after he robbed him like
of course people are gonna like know it
was him dps right now
and just see how far you is when you
leave just call me
[Music]
gonna be a head shot i'ma put this draco
in this dream
okay so he is going to this guy's house
to kill the guy that robbed him now i
just like to put a disclaimer kids
this is not the way to go if you get
robbed
go to the police do not kill the guy
that robbed you that's that's not the
good way to do it
but yeah he is going to kill the guy
because
now he knows that the guy was at the
stripper's house
he is trying to like ambush him at the
stripper's house
i'm gonna put this draco in this
dreadlock i can't wait to see his blood
running out run up in his
[Applause]
so she thinks she's about to get a booty
call but
she's getting more than that like it's
it's not going to be good he got in his
whip i ran up and i hit him
clear i saw him with the wrong [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] now i gotta kidnap her
it's the first [ __ ] i don't know how
kidnaps work imma kill him but i gotta
get my [ __ ] back first back first
damn be continued [ __ ]
damn you get this [ __ ]
come on okay so he this is
this is why i said you should not try to
kill somebody that robbed you like
that's not a good plan um so basically
what happened
was he realized after he shot him
that it was the wrong guy so now he's
kidnapping the stripper
we're gonna see how this goes um in
terms
of the song
okay i'll tell you what i liked about it
i liked that it told the story
the whole time i could understand what
he was saying and
i could follow along with what was
happening
in the video okay what i did not
like about the song was the whole
messaging like
you should not try to kill somebody that
robbed you
and you should not use a stripper just
because she
is for the streets to get to it that's
just not a good idea but
overall because i liked the b i'm gonna
give it like a seven
if you agree with my analysis let me
know
in the comments if you disagree also let
me know
in the comments and don't forget to like
comment
and subscribe especially subscribe i'ma
talk to you guys next time